a close encounter with a man-eating
giant a sorceress who turns men into
pigs a long-lost king taking back his
throne on their own any of these make
great stories but each is just one
episode in the Odyssey a 12,000 line
poem spanning years of ancient Greek
history
myth and legend how do we make sense of
such a massive text that comes from and
tells of a world so far away the fact
that we can read The Odyssey at all is
pretty incredible as it was composed
before the Greek alphabet appeared in
the 8th century BCE it was made for
listeners rather than readers and was
performed by oral poets called rap codes
tradition identifies its author as a
blind man named Homer but no one
definitively knows whether he was real
or legendary the earliest mentions of
him occurs centuries after his era and
the poems attributed to him seemed to
have been changed and rearranged many
times by multiple authors before finally
being written down in their current form
in fact the word rap code means
stitching together as these poets
combined existing stories joke myths and
songs into a single narrative to recite
these massive epics lives rap shows
employed a steady meter along with
mnemonic devices like repetition of
memorized passages or set pieces
these included descriptions of scenery
and lists of characters and help the
rhapsode keep their place in the
narrative just as the chorus or bridge
of a song helps us to remember the next
verses because most of the tales were
familiar to the audience it was common
to hear the sections of the poem out of
order at some point the order became set
in stone and the story was locked into
place as the one we read today
but since the world has changed a bit in
the last several thousand years it helps
to have some background before jumping
in the Odyssey itself is a sequel to
homers other famous epic The Iliad which
tells the story of the Trojan War if
there's one major theme uniting both
poems it's this do not under any
circumstances incur the wrath of the
gods the Greek pantheon is a dangerous
mix of divine power and human insecurity
prone to jealousy and grudges of epic
proportions and many of the problems
faced by humans in the poems are caused
by their hubris or excessive pride in
believing themselves superior to the
gods the desire to please the gods was
so great that the ancient Greeks
traditionally welcomed all strangers
into their homes with generosity for
fear that the strangers might be gods in
disguise this ancient code of
hospitality was called zhenia it
involves hosts providing their guests
with safety food and comfort and the
guests returning the favor with courtesy
and gifts if they had them zhenya has a
significant role in the Odyssey where
Odysseus and his wanderings is the
perpetual guest while in his absence his
clever wife Penelope plays non-stop host
the Odyssey recounts all of Odysseus as
years of travel but the narrative begins
in medias res in the middle of things
ten years after the Trojan War we find
our hero trapped on an island still far
from his native ethica and the family he
hasn't seen for 20 years because he's
angered to see God Poseidon by blinding
his son a cyclops Odysseus is passage
home has been fraught with mishap after
mishap but trouble brewing at home and
gods discussing his fate
Odysseus begins the account of those
missing years to his hosts one of the
most fascinating things about the
Odyssey is the gap between how little we
know about its time period and the
wealth of detail
the text itself contains historians
linguists and archaeologists have spent
centuries searching for the ruins of
Troy and identifying which islands
Odysseus visited just like its hero the
24 book epic has made its own long
journey through centuries of myth and
history to tell us its incredible story
today
[Music]
you